being a woman is not just about your  physical it's not just about your  biological okay what's your definition  then I can't  I can't even like Define it because you  designed yourself  how do you know you're a woman but I'm  Different to other women that have like  that I felt maybe like a man that felt  like he was a woman and then like  transformed I'm Different to that  because me I was born as a woman and I  would say I how do you know well I have  a I bleed I believe like three times do  men do about three times once you know I  think even even that in itself that  defines a woman doesn't it as a man have  you ever because a man ever had a period  in a menstrual cycle show me one there's  there's eight billion people in the  world just show me one